[Music]
15th century Europeans believed they had
hit upon a miracle cure a remedy for
epilepsy hemorrhage bruising nausea and
virtually any other medical ailment this
brown powder could be mixed into drinks
made into saps or eaten straight up it
was known as mummy ax and made by
grinding up mummified human flesh the
word cannibal dates from the time of
Christopher Columbus in fact Columbus
may even have coined it himself after
coming ashore on the island of Guadalupe
Columbus's initial reports back to the
Queen of Spain described the indigenous
people as friendly and peaceful though
he did mention rumors of a group called
the carrots who made violent raids and
then cooked and ate their prisoners in
response
Queen Isabella granted permission to
capture and enslave anyone who ate human
flesh when the island failed to produce
the gold Columbus was looking for he
began to label anyone who resisted his
plundering and kidnapping as a Caribe
somewhere along the way the word carob
became canna Bay and then cannibal first
used by colonizers to dehumanize
indigenous people it has since been
applied to anyone who eats human flesh
so the term comes from an account that
wasn't based on hard evidence but
cannibalism does have a real and much
more complex history it has taken
diverse forms sometimes as with Mumia it
doesn't involve recognisable parts of
the human body the reasons for
cannibalistic practices have varied -
across cultures and time periods there's
evidence of survival cannibalism when
people living through a famine siege or
ill-fated expedition had to either eat
the bodies of the dead or starve to
death themselves but it's also been
quite common for cultures to normalize
some form of eating human flesh under
ordinary circumstances
because of false accounts like
Columbus's it's difficult to say exactly
how common cultural cannibalism has been
but there are still some examples of
accepted cannibalistic practices from
within the cultures practicing them take
the medicinal cannibalism in Europe
during Columbus's time starting in the
15th century the demand for Mamiya
increased at first stolen mummies from
Egypt supplied the Mamiya craze but soon
the demand was too great to be sustained
on Egyptian mummies alone and
opportunists stole bodies from European
cemeteries to turn into mummy 'm use of
mummy a' continued for hundreds of years
it was listed in the Merc index a
popular medical encyclopedia into the
20th century and ground up mummies were
far from the only remedy made from human
flesh that was common throughout Europe
blood in either liquid or powdered form
was used to treat epilepsy while human
liver gall stones oil distilled from
human brains and pulverized hearts were
popular medical concoctions in China the
written record of socially accepted
cannibalism goes back almost 2,000 years
one particularly common form of
cannibalism appears to have been filial
cannibalism where adult sons and
daughters would offer a piece of their
own flesh to their parents this was
typically offered as a last-ditch
attempt to cure a sick parent and wasn't
fatal to their offspring it usually
involved flesh from the thigh or less
often a finger cannibalistic funerary
rites are another form of culturally
sanctioned cannibalism perhaps the
best-known example came from the for a
people of New Guinea through the mid
20th century members of the community
would if possible make their funerary
preferences known in advance sometimes
requesting that family members gather to
consume the body after death
tragically though these rituals honored
the deceased they also spread a deadly
disease known as kuru through the
unity between the fictionalized stories
verifiable practices and big gaps that
still exist in our knowledge there's no
one history of cannibalism but we do
know that people have been eating each
other
volunteering themselves to be eaten and
accusing others of eating people for
millennia
on a cannibalism kick check out this
video and meet some of the animal
kingdom's most conspicuous cannibals or
opt for something lighter with this
video
[Music]